[Music]
you just flew in from New York yeah he
here so you have the right to be tired
how was the flight flight was cool uh it
was uneventful which I like I just like
to fall asleep and wake up somewhere
else yeah
what is magical is magical is going to
sleep in you're here that's great
I haven't that is one other flight
sucked a while ago
what happened there's a celebrity on
there celebrity came on the plane Jimmy
Carter is he a celebrity yes the press
in the United States celebrity in
politics is that the same thing yeah a
president of the United States is always
a celebrity yeah he was wait he just
walked through and he was shaking
everybody's hands on a plane I thought
that was disgusting walk through he
didn't say hey he didn't get on the PA
say hey it's Jimmy Carter y'all want to
shake my hand if you want to shake my
hand raise your hand right just walk
towards that hey I'm former President
Jimmy Carter shake my nasty hand and saw
the person from 1a I was sitting in
coach he looked 30 to beat and I got the
dude from 1a stuff combined with the
personal fight is all types of gross
stuff what I'm saying is you got
everybody's germs before you on your
headband with Jimmy Carter
Jimmy Carter has the super bug on his
hand yeah it's disgusting yeah does it
every flight used to carry hand
sanitizer and don't you don't know my
politics now that's well we have a
picture we have a picture here he's
working his way towards you I love that
maybe it's a part of the flight maybe
he's there that's all he's there always
he's a delta representative
now I want to both have something in
common which is we both were at one time
staring at live writers I was curious if
your experience you know would you have
a pleasant experience there I was there
for was it you probably got sketches on
right I got scale got sketches on I
didn't get any sketches on you didn't
get any one no no I did how long were
you there for one season right okay once
gets on really so kind of good a good
ratio yeah what was it like when you
were there because I heard it changed
and that when I was there which was it
was so it was long ago it was one that
was a radio show where they even
televise it nobody back when I was there
the writers would stay up here for two
nights in a row we would stay up and it
almost became like a macho thing like
I'm gonna stay up longer than anybody
else yeah it's very late nice and one
time and I was in the middle of moving
because I just brought over my girls so
I slept at the office sometimes and so I
slept on off in officer Wednesday night
and we had to work Thursday and at noon
but I I was late to work even though I
slept at the office that's hard to pull
off that's hard to be late to work while
at work you know I'm supposed to do are
you a are you a deep sleeper are you so
when you're out are you really out I am
I do I sleep deeply something I fell
asleep one time I was waiting for the
subway in New York and I fell asleep I
was wearing a hat and I wake up and it's
a dude sitting two seats away from me
but he was wearing my hat that's New
York and I said wake I said hey man
that's my hat
give me my hat and he's you gave me the
Hat
I was confused so this either means I'm
very friendly when you wake me up from
my sleep he's just a bonus thief ever
because that boat isn't to steal
something from somebody and then fall
asleep two seats away from there wearing
what you stole I don't have any fears
I'm most confident man in the world
maybe I think was you being real nice
being drowsy to be like oh you can have
anything to you carry objects don't mean
anything just take